okay Hobbs is the founder and director
of we own it which campaigns for public
ownership zakat Romel its market value
is more than four billion pounds now I
mean compensating shareholders with that
money you could pay for twenty six
thousand nurses twelve thousand doctors
for two years it's better ways to spend
the money surely good evening we haven't
heard the full proposals on Royal Mail
but what I think is fantastic about this
announcement is that we know that public
ownership is really really popular when
you look at you go polling you can see
that for the Royal Mail for the energy
companies for the railway companies
there's a majority of people in this
country who want to see these services
brought into public ownership but that
cost of Rena lysing raw mail four
billion pounds I mean there's better
ways to spend money when the
government's got a fifty billion deficit
isn't well I think we need to take a
long view which is exactly what the
government didn't do when they sawed off
the Royal Mail the Royal Mail was sold
off for around three billion pounds at
that time it was making a profit of
three hundred million pounds a year so
we've done research with the New
Economics foundation showing that within
ten years we're going to be worse off
the British public will be worse off
because of that sale now that was a
short-term decision and we need to take
some long-term decisions to bring public
assets into public hands how much would
you compensate shareholders that's a
question that would have to be decided
but is it a good deal to have public
profits going back into the public purse
absolutely well let's have a look at the
railways then I mean real privatisation
has been a huge success in terms of
passenger journeys passenger journeys
have doubled in the last 20 years in the
35 last years of British Rail they fell
by 1/3 well under British Rail we saw a
lot of under investment by the
government on purpose but what I would
say is if you're a passenger and you're
looking at the outrageous fares that
people are paying which are high at the
highest fares in Europe if you're on a
packed carriage trying to get to work I
think you'd question the idea that our
railways are a success well hold on
that's because we're trying to get the
passengers themselves to pay for the
railways rather than tax pays that's
good thing isn't it well the thing is
that if you brought the railways into
public ownership you could actually save
1.2 billion pounds a year and that money
could be used to reduce fares or to make
better said you were that hurt so that's
from a rebuilding Rail report and that
basically shows the money from the
shareholder profits but also the money
that comes from having a more
grated system because right now our
railway is very very fragmented and it's
a real mess so if you integrated that
system and you reinvested the profits
back into the system you would have a
more efficient system but the rail
operators make a margin of just three
pence in the pound I mean that's not
going to be enough to cut fares
meaningfully is it I mean also bear in
mind I mean since privatisation the
railways are now actually more or less
paying for themselves they never ever
did that in the whole nationalization
rope the RO is receive a huge amount of
subsidy and what we've seen is that
public ownership is much more efficient
so we saw that with the East Coast
franchise in 2009 the company failed on
the East Coast franchise the government
came in and ran it in public ownership
for five years until 2014 it returned 1
billion pounds to the Treasury
it was the most efficient franchise in
the UK so I think public ownership works
really well and we've got an ideological
problem here that says Oh surely private
companies have to do everything no they
don't look at it something's interposed
everything
East Coast returned 1 billion over five
years in private hands I mean Virgin
Trains East Coast is going to return 3.3
billion over eight years that's a much
better paren and return to the taxpayer
if you look at the comparison figures at
the time East Coast got to the point
where it was receiving zero subsidy
while the Virgen comparable line was
receiving quite a bit of subsidy so it's
basically it was the most efficient rail
line in the UK and the statistics well
isn't that because it's got competition
on that I mean East Coast has
competition from whole trains and great
center of GrandCentral I mean it's it's
competition that spurred this
improvement isn't it no no when when
East Coast was run was running public
ownership it was able to retrieve more
money and it returned that money to the
public purse so so when you're when
you've got a service run in public
ownership you're not wasting money on
shareholder profits three three pence in
the pound doesn't sound a waste really
but we but we needn't waste that money
we could reinvest that money for the
benefit of passengers and we know that
66 percent of people want to see the
railway in public ownership because
they're sick of it
and if you if you talk to somebody on
you know in a train platform about
competition you know they're going to
say well the next train that comes along
that's the train I'm getting on one one
last question cat why should why should
less well-off passenger and most train
journeys are into London every day why
should less well-off passengers
subsidize people commuting into the
to the city every day well I think the
railway is good for our economy and it's
good for the country as a whole it takes
cars off the road if it's a good
alternative for people so there are
always an important part of how people
get around but it needs to be in public
ownership all right cat hops going to
leave it there thanks a lot